the direct path
number six welcome
we are refining these direct
path transmissions
i hope you enjoy the clarity of this one
we're also covering a lot of additional
bases
on the path to self-realization
and their very important cornerstones
to prepare people for as they end up
encountering
those cornerstones and having that
wisdom
to get through them quickly and
efficiently
and piercing the veil
to self-realize
the key indirect path number six is
discernment
a high level of discernment across all
of these stages
we'll be referencing that throughout
again i encourage you to be in an
environment
that has no noise pollution where you
can sit comfortably
alone
get yourself to a place where the monkey
mind is not
running rampantly use your breath
to drop into the now
so number one is attributes
these are the layers to our onion the
layers of identity
the layers to ego
as we peel off those attributes
those layers of identity and ego
we get more and more towards
number two which is the pure bear
awareness of the
i am so we shed the layers of identity
and we recognize the most pure the most
bear the most empty the most primal
aspect to our awareness being the very i
ness to that awareness awareness the
very
business the very beingness
and the process of enlightenment is the
recognition
that that awareness is eternal
that awareness is infinite that
awareness
is nature is bliss and peace
it has been here before now it will be
here after now it has eternally been
having a pure and bare empty awareness
be
colored by thoughts feelings beliefs
emotions objects so enlightenment is the
process
by which we recognize that very
i am-ness that pure bear empty awareness
being eternal being infinite in its
nature being bliss in peace
and the light may flicker a little
small satori moments here and there
but then we re-baseline ourselves
this is the process that i'm in right
now as well we re baseline ourselves
to make that home so the light stays on
permanently
and that is where we begin getting into
number three the absolute
that is where we go even beyond the i am
the beyond the pure bear awareness to
what
is agentless
to what is attribute less
in a sense we dig back far enough in our
awareness
and get to the pure bear empty
awareness of the i am
recognize that that is eternal infinite
bliss peace
and then we go another step
and that step requires a high level
of discernment discernment enables
subtlety
it requires the discernment and subtlety
to
understand what the layers of identity
are that are on the onion to be able to
shed those
peel those and get to number two
pure bear empty awareness of i am
and then again the subtlety and the
discernment in order to understand that
that is infinite that that is eternal
it's nature's bliss and peace
and then one more
subtle discernment to go even
beyond the agent
go beyond the agent of the i am
go beyond even the attributes
of the i am being an experiencer
that is having an experience
go beyond even that
to a state of just
indescribable perfection
indescribable infinite
perfection
that absolute to re baseline
to make that home
is the full direct path
to self-realization
and just to be clear that doesn't mean
that you can't come back in
hey hey let's dance a bit let's
celebrate let's party it
up yeah let's go on a hike let's go on a
stroll let's live it up
hey you can do both
the first step is to undergo
the self-realization
and that way the expression
of the one infinite creator
of that absolute
is of the absolute highest morality
and ethics and love and compassion
in maximizing well-being and prosperity
and abundance
for all
so that's the core of the direct path
number six
the key being discernment across all
these stages
number one the attributes peeling
the layers of the onion
peeling those layers of identity down to
the pure bear
empty primal awareness of the number two
of i am
recognizing that that i am
that very blank paper
that is eternal infinite and its nature
is bliss and peace
is being colored by words
of objects feelings emotions thoughts
and beliefs
eternally
across an infinite amount of creation
designs
with completely different vehicles of
sentience
consciousness awareness i am-ness to
experience
and beyond that
is the recognition the discernment
the most subtle
agentlessness attributelessness
of the absolute
in a sense the complete
opposite of the oneness and the unity
the agentlessness the attributelessness
the indescribable perfection
of that absolute
i hope this has been valuable for you
i'm glad that we were able to keep this
one short
that was my goal so go ahead and
re-listen to it
congratulations on any of the progress
that you've made
it's very important
like the video share it with people that
need to hear it
catalyze more of the self-realization
live in a more harmonic
society
let me know how you feel and where
you're at in the comments below
as well and i'll do my best to get in
there and reply
subscribe if you haven't please
move away from the mass media
at minimum move towards the
self-actualization media
and at best move towards
self-realization
media we've linked
several of the best teachers in the
bio below for you to check out we love
you very much
thank you for tuning in
recognize yourself as that
absolute agentless
attributeless indescribable
perfection
you